I have a story that when I tell it to
you uh you might think it's a story not
from the United Kingdom but this is a
story from Nottingham in the UK the
jamia all who da girls school in
nottingham UK is an Islamist girls
boarding school which fortunately is
facing closure after a former student
exposed that it is essentially a Sharia
inspired school and I'll explain what
that means at the school uh the all
female student body is taught that men
can beat women and that gay people
should be killed sort of as a matter of
of course as a matter of normal life
alia Salim was expelled in front of the
entire student body in 2006 she was
accused of quote narcissism for owning a
disposable camera and she was publicly
humiliated as part of her punishment now
you might hear this in stay yet you know
David it's sad but we hear stories like
this all the time from from certain
other countries uh and your reaction
wouldn't be wrong but this is from the
United Kingdom this is not from a
country where we would say yeah well of
course their students and kids being
taught this stuff reading the headline I
thought great uh there is a country that
uh has been riddled with this type of
problem for a long time and they're
saying no more we are shutting the
school down and then I realize we're
talking about nottingham now after being
expelled uh miss Celine spoke out about
how she was treated at the school she
said that they were not taught any
geography they were not taught any
history they weren't taught art or
sports or music they were instead taught
extremist views they were taught that
the death sentence is something that can
and should be given to gay men they were
taught that Jews make a la angry and she
said I left the school programmed to be
anti-semitic and to believe things that
just are not compatible with daily life
in Nottingham I was effectively unable
to live a normal life in British society
and uh now that more has been found out
about the jamia AL Huda school they've
been instructed to close their boarding
facilities because the boarding
facilities don't have enough safeguards
in terms of preventing a culture of
bullying which reportedly exists the
staff is poorly trained this is not
actually forcing this book school to
close technically but eighty-five
percent of the students are border so
effectively this is going to shut down
the school and by the way the school was
not performing even close to national
standards twenty five percent of the
students this year achieved five a
through c GCSE grades which is a
national of uh standard that exists in
the UK twenty-five percent achieving
that compared to the national average of
fifty three percent what's really
disturbing to me is that even after we
found out what was going on at the
school what was being taught at the
school they were only shut down because
of bureaucratic inadequacies right the
teaching of hateful anti-western
anti-semitic and anti woman rhetoric did
not actually put the school in danger if
they were able to pass this inspection
right if they had the right staff in the
boarding area the in the in the the
dorms they would have been able to stay
open fortunately we've had a series of
events which makes it so that they are
going to be closing can you be
deprogrammed after spending years at a
school like this i mean that i know that
theoretically it can be done but if
you've spent four five six years in a
school we're number one you're
completely behind on everything you
should be learning because you've been
taught no history you've been taught no
math what else was it that they weren't
teaching them geography art sports music
you've been taught none of that so
number one you're already behind
relative to sort of the broader
population that's your age and number
two you've been programmed for years to
believe that it's perfectly normal for
men to beat women it's perfectly normal
that gay people should be killed it's
perfectly normal that Jews are just
genuinely and fundamentally back
an anti semitism isn't something that we
should be moving away from but it's a
something that you should embrace you
can be deprogrammed but it would take a
very very long time and I'd be curious
to hear I know that there are many
people in our audience who have told me
that they they went to uh most mostly
Christian but there are some Muslims and
a few Jews in our audience who have been
to what I would certainly described as
extremist religious academies for their
own religions and they have successfully
been deprogrammed for lack of a better
term write to me and tell me what was
that process like how long did that take